okay [ __ ] we are now doing Hale
center and where we gotta go we gotta go
to the dark brother sanctuary I think
we're doing this like one last missions
check you can do this but just 60 frames
per second light as data and death where
is she where is it the penis again all
with you that's why man I have Lydia
with the sexy mouth oh my god [ __ ] 2
rolling out my mic I'm gonna break it by
fittest what a mess I guess this is the
end what well what is a maund MultiAir
but then your ability NASA night at me
ah listen and come back with a barrel
full of gold know that bet my girl
accurate but why isn't my [ __ ] up why
is that why is this [ __ ] that on there
we go we're moved
okay let's do this let's go look at sexy
ilaria okay let's do that oh la comida y
ando Tom Paine's and oh I can take on
take a salt on there I bet when I where
the [ __ ] you were
and yeah [ __ ] a horse
there we go [ __ ] I gotta get out here
the van oord mare oh yeah let me know if
you want anything if it's worth looking
for holders for one to talk what is it I
said I didn't wish to be disturbed or
any time God please you mustn't think I
had anything to do with that I want to
be up you mean after pie this is us the
Emperor is still in Skyrim but not for
long he's on board his ship the Couture
I animal if you can get on board that
ship kill Titus meet the second as
contracted I will reveal the location of
the dead drop well it's in the solitude
inlet I suppose you should go to the
docks and swim and let's do this Lydia
oh that kind of mass say kind of
foreplay out didn't it okay so now we're
gonna get to the ship that's great
lacrosse the flight [ __ ] like [ __ ] my
dick hole right we can take groups of
people I'm like wow love the cold
yeah Lydia sweat and then have panties
that's for sure ok I'll later okay we're
going to find this one the [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] am i doing
yeah is that right a stout
that's right st. up out where's the boat
yep that's about
okay so I got to get on board
ok
where are you
pocket
still hold for me to answer now there's
one perfect
we're going to get these [ __ ] a lock
pick
looks like one of the doctor and it's a
[ __ ] soon
[Music]
never get upstairs
and once more I proof Commander Marlowe
the fool okay
today thing get here
Shh by some [ __ ] that they were rare in
here
well considering it all the [ __ ] food
get-get
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
the cats gatos did you there we're
looking for someone in wife Ron will
take good money for information yeah a
woman a foreigner in these she is likely
not using her true we are not welcome
here in white so we will be in rohrich
you have to learn to my career yeah come
on in let me know if you need anything
take a seat by the fire and I'll send
someone else haha you're back I know I
know my friends you may not realize it
but you have sir but you care little for
your payment wait for you at a dead drop
it is inside now please go collect your
money and let us never get on one
another again our reasonably see you
gone to share the payment real quick I
can't bear chance let's share the pain
yeah don't forget that like the left
right yeah
Oh
ok
man what the [ __ ] do I have to go like a
million places [ __ ] out a figure that
cave thing yeah just go back Hit sir hi
big diamond a plot Selma flyers okay
clean that up
hey I've got a boss not my pal
ok
well what word of the Emperor truly
could you have brought us more wondrous
despite your misfortunes you stage now
of course I must ask killing the Emperor
ah right now might I offer some advice
Mallory is an expert obtainer of goods
we can use them you do that and I'll see
what I can do about recruiting some new
additions to our class okay thanks for
watching